let's say I have some type of a surface
let's say that this right over here is
the top of your desk and I were to draw
a triangle on that surface
so maybe the triangle looks like this
something like this it doesn't have to
be a right triangle and so I'm not
implying that this is necessarily a
right triangle although it looks a
little bit like one and let's call it
triangle a B and then C now what I'm
going to do is something interesting I'm
going to take a fourth point P that's
not on the surface of this desk and I'm
it's going to be right above point B so
let me just take that point go straight
up and I'm going to get to point P right
over here now what I can do is construct
a pyramid using point P as the peak of
that pyramid now what we're going to
start thinking about is what happens if
I take cross sections of this pyramid so
in this case the length of segment PB is
the height of this pyramid now if we
were to go half way along that height
and if we were to take a cross section
of this pyramid that is parallel to the
surface of our original desk what would
that look like well it would look
something it would look something like
this
now you might be noticing something
really interesting if you were to
translate that blue triangle straight
down onto the surface of the table it
would look like this and when you see it
that way it looks like it is a dilation
of our original triangle centered at
point B and in fact it is a dilation
centered at point B with a scale factor
of 0.5 and you can see it right over
here this length right over here what BC
was dilated down to is half the length
of the original BC this is half the
length of the original a B and then this
is half the length of the original AC
but you could do it at other heights
along this pyramid
what if we were to go point seven-five
of the way between P and B so if we were
to go right over here so it's closer to
our original triangle closer to our
surface so then the cross-section would
look like would look like this now if we
were to translate that down onto our
original surface what would that look
like well it would look like this it
would look like a dilation of our
original triangle centered at point B
but this time with a scale factor of
0.75 and then what if you were to go
only 1/4 of the way between point P and
point B well then you would see
something like this 1/4 of the way to
take the cross-section parallel to our
original surface it would look like this
if you were to translate that straight
down onto our table it would look
something like this and it looks like a
dilation centered at point B with a
scale factor of 0.25 and the reason why
all of these dilations look like
dilation centered at point B is because
point P is directly above point B but
this is a way to conceptualize dilations
or see the relationship between
cross-sections of a [ __ ] of a
three-dimensional shape in this case
like a pyramid and how those cross
sections relate to the base of the
pyramid now let me ask you an
interesting question what if I were to
try to take a cross-section right at
Point P well then I would just get a
point I would not get an actual triangle
but you could view that as a dilation
with a scale factor of 0 and what if I
were to take a cross-section at the base
well then that would be my original
triangle triangle ABC and then you can
view that as a dilation with a scale
factor of 1 because you've gone all the
way down to the base so hopefully this
connects some dots for you
between cross-sections of a 3
mental shape that is parallel to the
base and notions of dilation